are you friends with any the guys that
you've dated in the past like kept them
around sort of as a friend mhm most of
them all of them none of them like one
or two of them most of them okay what
about if you met a guy and he ticked off
all the
boxes and you guys had like a talk and
it was all hey you know moof I dig your
Vibe I don't want to share you with
anybody uh you know where do we stand
are we going to be exclusive and he said
well you know I like you too but I can't
take a chick seriously that keeps guys
from her pastor around like how would
you handle
[Music]
that um I
mean remember you're coming to him like
he's like he's the one you know I choose
you I don't want to see anybody else
other men have now become invisible but
his Line in the Sand is we're not going
to get married we're not going to have
kids like you know it's exactly all the
stuff you want but but his Line in the
Sand is I can't take a woman seriously
that has men from her pass around uh
um you can't be going out and having
coffee and lunch with them and chatting
and texting and stuff like
that that's hard because like some of
these friendships like have been since I
was a kid like so I mean yeah but you
were also intimate with them at one
point
too right
um I think that's hard
because like with some our families are
so twin that they're on every family
vacation like that we're going on so
also if you go on a family vacation one
of these guys might potentially be on
one of the family vacations so it's hard
for you
to kick them out sort of thing right
it's not just me it's my family as well
how Okay so maybe I need to get some
frame around so your family goes for
vacation let's say you do like a
Thanksgiving somewhere his family is
there as well he'll be there you'll be
like how many of these family events
happen with these two families colliding
where there's guys involved in it
because there's more than one guy the
way that you're describing
it
um well that situation I would say
that's
just one specific person um where it's
multiple events at multiple family
events as well
um
with like would you be okay with a guy
keeping a girl from his past
around it depends on how far long in the
past it was doesn't matter you know four
years ago they were married they got
divorced uh you know I mean they were
together for seven years
whatever they want to get together and
have dinner and coffee from time to time
you're not
invited you're not included in the
chat I think as long as you're being
open you can see the problem right I
think as long as you're being open and
honest about what you're doing and you
are being clear with every motive and
transparent with what everything is
you're not trying to hide it you're
being
upfront
um I don't think that there's a concern
when it comes to that it's when you
start to hide things and you start being
secretive and you are trying to hide
chats or you're trying to hide
conversations or it's becoming awkward
when both people are around then that's
when there's cause for concern I
wouldn't say that there's cause for
concern just because there is a past so
I have a question so as far as because
you look you said what you're looking
for is we we would be in a monogamous
relationship or kind of like partnership
companionship there um at least when I
view that idea sharing the intimacy just
between you and another person um do you
feel like if they you know if they were
talking to like you know the situation
that Rich laid out their ex-wife they
were you know you were left out of it
they were consistently hanging out and
going out
um you feel like that would be about
being consistently left out right well I
guess even if he was you know telling
you what was going on you feel like even
you know but you're not there you're
you're getting whatever story you know
is being given to don't you feel like
that would be some sort of intimacy
still that he's sharing with another
woman while you guys are in a monogamous
relationship whether just a friendship
friend friendship not I mean I just I
don't see how men and women can really
have just like a friendship like that
especially when you've been intimate
with the person I think it comes down to
trust of the other person and your
confidence in that relationship you
can't just worry about if the other
person's going to cheat or not like
they're going to cheat if they're going
to cheat but if you continually worry
about it then that's when it becomes an
issue I mean you think it's controlling
if you if you set those boundaries like
I'm think that those are boundaries that
you can definitely bring up in the
relationship but those are something
that you talk about together and come to
right but I mean if like a guy just said
flat out look hey you know we've been
dating and you know you come to him and
you know he's he's 6 foot he's athletic
he makes 150,000 he's 30 years old no
kids doesn't want kids wants to be
monogamous likes traveling like you do
and all that sort of stuff do you think
it's controlling if he says hey look you
know these guys from your past you're
gonna have to let them go if you want to
be serious with me I definitely think
there are people that I would be able
to make that accommodation
for okay that's good I mean like there's
some things that I'm hearing and I'm
asking these questions to sort of get a
little bit of clarity in the way that
you believe the world to operate
because I follow this channel from
results to choices to beliefs because
beliefs govern the choices that we make
every day which will get us the results
that we experience in our lives right so
if
you're I mean like a game that you can
play is you know when you're at the
grocery store and you look at what
somebody puts on the conveyor belt when
they're checking out and what they look
like there's always a direct correlation
between what they eat and what they look
like right and I think that that that's
true for a lot of other areas in life
Success With Money success with network
with influence you know with people that
they hang out with the stuff that they
do sort of stuff right so there's always
these direct correlations and these
results flow down this channel of
results choices beliefs right so I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out